les fans de johnny sont en colère en
cause la manière dont la tombe du père
de john eales et on se met a été
totalement abandonnée et risquent d'être
supprimés la concession de les ans med
situé à schaerbeek arrive à son terme et
sans renouvellement elle pourrait
disparaître
il ya quelques jours véronique une
habitante de la région s'est aperçu que
sa tombe
allez tout bonnement être supprimés
c'est choquant c'est la seule personne
de la famille semaine qui est enterré
chez nous un article qui a fait du bruit
et fait bouger les choses puisque les
enfants et la veuve de la star ont
vivement réagi comme david hallyday qui
a décidé de prendre l'affairé en main
le caveau sera toujours la paix à son
âme alors le caveau de l'est on souhaite
battre finalement être conservé et la
colère des fans est elle justifiée pour
donner des alors tu as fait fabien tu
sais que tu es occupé longtemps de co2
françois prat étaient proches de lui
regardez là tu vois quelqu'un est là
tout va bien
autant tout cas ce qu'on peut voir c'est
que fabien il est toujours sympa
ossements fabien toujours là pour faire
un compliment
même quand on peut penser non fabien
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
là de johnny hallyday va du père de
johnny hallyday c'est un fait divers
classé qui arrive à tous les gens de
notre société c'est à dire que quand on
achète une sépulture
ouais on sait qu'il ya une concession à
perpétuité qui a réellement de trente
années
d'accord il se trouve que le père de
johnny la concession qui avaient été
prises en belgique lorsqu'il est décédé
en 1989 avait été prise pour 30 ans et
donc au 31 décembre 2020 on arrivait
hélas ce qui se passe quand personnes se
manifestent on déterre les gens dans les
personnes c'est magnifique on les met
dans une petite boîte parce que il faut
trente ans pour que les le corps se met
en poussière les eaux et quelques
vêtements
on vous met ça dans une pub le profond
les gens c'est sympa et après et on
revend la place sa voix est ce parce
c'est quand même très ennuyeux moi
j'aime bien que ça arrive ça par exemple
ses parents qui étaient au père lachaise
depuis 89
j'ai dû racheter la concession au nom de
michel polnareff ah oui pour pour pas
qui des terres et qui remettent
quelqu'un la place j'en avais beaucoup
des concessions de taille en a partout
donc la belle affaire du fait sept morts
le garder
la sphère johnny c'est une affaire qui
arrive c'est incroyable et il faut se
manifester je crois que laura et david
se seraient manifestés alors bon c'est
ça la concession à bas ils vont la
racheter ça coûte rien c'est entre 350
et 600 euros ouais ça coûte rien pas
tomber en voiture qui n'accorde c'est
pas c'est pas en france c'est rien il
faut surtout qu'ils soient au courant et
le problème qui a eu que deux modèles
éthiciens à côté david et laura c'est
personne n'avait prévenu puisque comme
c'est le cimetière de 2 chère beach
indiquant en cottage
béchir bic et donc à personne les avait
prévenus
donc c'est aussi simple que ça
l'histoire c'est pas mais bon il faut
faire attention parce que ça peut être
très dangereux
effectivement et puis c'est un lien très
fort entre la belgique et la france
jeune ali daei à ce lien du papa et de
la famille belge de l'est on se met lui
hors norme et moi j'ai encore une fois
les enchères big ouais mais on se met
lui rendre une fois en 70 ans avait été
vu dans un concert de johnny à ce moment
là il était là dans les chorales johnny
what is well et on se met c'est fou ça
il est titulaire de son fils n'ont rien
avant d'ailleurs qu'il est parti
maintenant ils savaient johnny avait 8
ans mélanie six de ses huit mois pour
essayer de revenir quand on avait besoin
d'argent
voilà c'est ça oui voilà bien un
événement qui avait troqué ses histoires
là sur le père de dieu l'histoire elle
est terrible il a abandonné il a quitté
le foyer ans en réseau on l'a vu l'âge
de 8 mois et non il n'a jamais jamais
ici de revenir il est alcoolique normes
on l'a dit non non non il avait monté
une opération pour revoir son fils en
mai milan s'auto fin quand l'alarmé
était à l'arrêt mais voilà avec une
équipe de france dimanche voilà excepté
rats pour essayer qu'il avait vendu pour
5000 francs de là le sujet la france
dimanche royal qui se trouve que les
jours ni l'aval prix a bien sûr à ce que
lui voue la reynard son papa oui mais
oui mais il son père il voulais le
revoir son père il a il a abandonné à
huit mois avec des chats alors je
précise alain bernard il l'abandonné à 8
mois et la raison d'ailleurs mais
surtout il l'a reconnu un an plus tard
c'est à dire le 16 septembre 44
ouais ce qui est quand même étonnant
pour la voirie soirée pire que ça joris
johnny qui m'avait raconté d'histoires
et m'avait plu confirmé qu'elle était
vrai il avait refusé de voir son père
tellement ils en avaient souffert et
quand il était alors mais son supérieur
le dit non tu peux pas faire ça un père
c'est un père s'y fait un pas vers toi
faut faire un pas vers lui aussi donc
demi
effectivement il voit son père que tout
seul qui m'offre un énorme ans en plus
en me disant ben voila tu vois sa selle
nos retrouvailles et tout est à ce
moment là il avait 45 ans sorte de
symbole est là il arpente réputé des
appareils photo et effectivement que
tous les photographes sorte sorte de des
fourrés et ils sont et devenir se rend
compte que ce soit là et que pour la
publicité
alors c'est peut-être normal aussi alors
que des personnes alors j'ai eu johnny
avait été parfaitement magnanime après
puisque au succès de ses pairs dans son
hymne à lille était quasiment le seul
vous vous rendez compte ils ont fait
arrêter il était seul son père était
enterrée il était là à suivre et moi je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui la colère des fans
pour répondre à la question elle est
justifiée parce que la famille sous la
pression va reprendre la concession mais
il aurait pu il aurait dû s'intéresser
au père bill alors noël chr bec car ils
n'ont pas cher bien on dit schirmeck
cheb bilal moi je trouve ça
insupportable les fans de johnny on a le
sentiment qu'ils veulent contrôler non
seulement toute la vie de john et lâcher
les mets toute la vie de ses proches
laetitia l'idée quand elle arrive au
mais qui sont pas content là la tombe du
père ça fait 30 ans que les disparus et
ce n'est pas content non plus ça met une
pression sur la famille david hallyday
il est obligé de se justifier et dire
vous inquiétez pas beaucoup géré le
dossier
ça regarde personne c'est un supporter
tranquille non mais cette année ils
veulent il va l'aider justement je suis
tenu à faire perdurer les volontés de
johnny doit savoir que johnny il a
toujours aidé son père malgré l'abandon
et l'absence quand il était à l'armée du
salut il lui a trouvé un logement en
situe lui acheter des costumes ses
costumes son père et les a revendues
pour s'acheter des bouteilles d'alcool
mais malgré tout johnny ne l'a jamais
abandonné dont je pense qu'ils veulent
lui faire perdurer cette volonté ouais
il leur faudra remonter et il a foutu le
feu à l'appartement plus important club
est louée johnny johnny a toujours
essayé de bain bourré ou je sais pas
quoi sur aimez johnny et toute sa vie à
essayer de recoller les morceaux avec
son père ça c'était la grande blessure
il posait toujours cette question il me
parlait toujours comment il est ton père
moi je me souviens d'un demi-millier
comment il est ton papa comment il
s'était très touchant
cet homme de cet âge là qui me parlait
de pas parce qu'un père ça reste un père
et moi serge reggiani et nous laissa
il peut vous faire les paires chassard
est un papa et je pense qu'à un moment
donné
serge reggiani avec m'avait raconté un
jour d'une interview que ça les jeunes
serge reggiani
c'est quand même beaucoup ramé 51 ces
mêmes délires grand grand chanteur était
un grand acteur et qui a été et ça a été
l'élève de léonce met le papa de johnny
est un très grand professeur d'art
dramatique il faut le rappeler quand
même aussi est un grand mais vous savez
que je connais tous reggiani parker
employés oui il est tombé dubaï aurait
dit des loups à l'ailé où les ventes
sont entrés dans paris soit par ici soit
paris free mais loups sont entrés dans
paris et aux obsèques aux autres d'y
aller je connais étonnant grave c'est
que johnny sert il je rejoins geely
n'était pas tout à fait seul johnny
avait quand même adeline qui était sa
future épouse
évidemment qui était présenté avec
quatre gardes du corps et un secrétaire
alors c'est vrai que c'est quand même
terrible d'enterrer un papa comme ça il
avait ni famille ni collaborateur ni ni
amis et ça c'est mental
si je dis pas de bêtises la concession a
déjà été renouvelée une voyelle non pas
par la mi mai par une association de
seulement juste un dernier mot pour
assurer donc les fans a effectivement
david et leur avance en occuper et
laetitia aussi elle a promis de s'en
occuper et de régler ce qui a réglé